- You're going to learn some tips
to speak clearly and confidently.
Specifically,
you'll learn how to speak
with more conviction.
This is part five in a five part series
on "How to Speak Clearly and Confidently."
This is the last video
and it's 100% compatible
with every other lesson
and tip in the series.
If you've been watching the series
and still haven't subscribed yet,
then you can do that right now
and if you're finding
these lessons helpful,
then feel free to check out my
Communication Coach Academy.
We have loads of free resources there,
group coaching options
and a variety of classes
and communication,
public speaking and leadership.
Today's video is all about
speaking with conviction
and the bottom line is if
you have something to say,
say it like you mean it.
Tip number one, to speak
with more conviction
is to increase your volume.
I would say that more
than half of the clients
I work with do not speak loudly enough
in group situations or
during presentations.
The trouble is,
people who speak softly
generally do not sound confident
in what they're saying.
If you speak at a below average volume,
it's going to create a
below average impression.
In contrast,
if you can increase your
volume by just 10 or 20%,
everything you say will
sound more enthusiastic
and committed.
If you're in a one-on-one
conversation of course,
you have to keep the level
of volume conversational,
but in front of a group
of almost any size,
increase your volume by about 10 or 20%.
For public speaking the tip
is to let your voice fill the room.
The larger the room and the
more people that are there,
the more volume you use.
When you speak a little louder,
it'll make everything you say,
like you're speaking with conviction.
When I work with clients,
we'll often do this in workshops
with somebody who is speaking
too softly for the room.
They volunteer and we put them up there
in front of everybody.
We're really supportive
and we gradually get them to speak louder.
And you can try this with me right now
and I'm going to use a sample
sentence about pickleball
from a previous lesson in this series.
We'll gradually increase the volume
and it's just a pickleball,
but you'll see how this
makes a difference.
Repeat the sentence after me
in your normal speaking volume.
Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around.
Now, let's say that again,
and this time let's speak 10% louder
and let your voice start to
fill whatever room you're in.
Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around.
Now, let's increase the
volume one more time
to 20% higher than your normal volume
and say it again with me.
Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around.
Now, I'm not there with you,
but I'm willing to speculate
that when you speak a little louder,
you'll sound more confident
and convinced about what you just said.
You may also notice as you
practice speaking louder,
that you're benefiting
from a few other positive side effects.
I've noticed that
when most of my clients
increase their volume,
they also increase their vocal variety
in the sound of their voice.
So, they no longer sound monotone.
That's because increasing
your volume naturally,
improves your tone and inflection.
My clients also usually
start to become more animated
in terms of their gestures
in their body language
and their facial expressions.
I can't obviously see you right now,
but let me ask, did you notice
that your facial expressions
became more animated
when you increased your volume?
Did you gesture with your
hands without realizing it?
All of that will make you
come across as more confident
in what you're saying.
So, all you have to do
is increase your volume
by about 10% or 20%
and you'll look and sound
like you're speaking
with more conviction.
Tip number two to speak
with more conviction
is to emphasize the most
important words in each sentence.
In fact, I just did that
in my previous sentence,
so I'll do it again
and you tell me which words I emphasized.
To speak with more conviction,
emphasize the most important
words in each sentence.
Did you hear it?
And you can do the same.
All I did was slow down and
lean into what I consider
to be the most important words,
and you should do that
in every single sentence.
Just pick whatever two
or three words in a row
that matter the most in each sentence.
Slow down and add emphasis to them.
There are lots of reasons
to emphasize key words.
The first is that when
people speak too rapidly
and rush through every
thought and every sentence,
it doesn't sound confident.
It sounds like they're just
trying to get through a message
and their main goal is
to get it over with.
Now, rushing through may
help you accomplish the goal
of finishing as fast as possible,
but it's not going to make you sound,
like you believe what you're saying.
Another reason people rush is
because of anxiety and nerves,
but whatever reason you have
for speaking too quickly,
emphasizing the most
important words in each
and every sentence will give you
a much more confident sounding rhythm.
It also helps your listeners,
because now they know
that if it's important
to you as a speaker,
then you're signaling that it
should be important to them.
And here's another tip within a tip.
When you get to the end
of your talking turn,
make sure you use the
same type of emphasis
on the last three words you say
and make sure your voice
goes down at the end,
toward the period punctuation mark.
It should sound like you
are landing the plane
on your talking turn.
Let's use our pickleball example again
and say it along with me.
We'll pretend that this is
the end of our talking turn.
Emphasize the last three
words as you read this
and notice how certain you sound.
Pickleball is now one of the
most popular sports around.
You really wanna lean into
those last three words.
Make sure it sounds like
you're making a statement
and not asking a question.
Third, let's talk eye contact
and how you can use this
to come across as more confident,
like you really believe
what you just said.
Before I give you this tip,
let me explain how I learned this myself.
I've been going to group
meetings as a participant
and coaching clients for decades now
and I've noticed a very subtle behavior
that differentiates the
most confident speakers
from everybody else in the room.
First and most obviously,
confident speakers tend
to make direct eye contact
with people as they're speaking.
That's probably not too surprising
and I would guess like most people,
you make at least some direct eye contact
when you're speaking, but if you don't,
make sure you practice eye contact,
while you're speaking
and sharing your message.
A second,
here's the subtle difference
I noticed about eye contact.
When the most confident speakers
finish their talking turns,
they keep their eyes and their chin up
and they continue to make eye
contact with the next person
in the group who speaks.
They don't stare or
glare at the next person
in a confrontational way.
They simply maintain eye contact
with whoever speaks next.
In contrast, professionals
who seem to lack confidence
in what they said,
finish their talking turn
and then they drop their eyes
and their chin toward the table,
toward their notes or toward a device.
And when they break eye contact like that
and look down after they speak,
it creates the impression
that they don't believe in
or stand behind what they just said.
To reiterate the tip,
when you finish your talking
turn in a group situation,
keep your chin up,
maintain eye contact
with whoever speaks next
and it will cast a very positive light
on what you just said
and it'll come across like
you stand behind your message.
If you watched all five
videos in this series
on how to speak clearly and confidently,
please let me know in a comment.
I would love to celebrate that
with you with my own comment,
and I will give you a heart.
And don't forget to take
a look at my website.
There's free resources
there that I mentioned,
group coaching options and classes.
Thank you for joining me in this journey.
Until next time, thanks.
God bless, and I will see you soon.